newly indicted as a war criminal
President Putin made an unexpected trip
to the very City where many of those
crimes are alleged to have been
perpetrated
described as a working trip to Marriott
ball the president met members of the
public who appeared to be on the streets
Way Before Dawn on a Sunday morning
stop for a chat move
ment
distributed by state media Mr Putin is
shown driving himself around town on his
first visit to Ukrainian territory
occupied by Russian forces
he visited newly refurbished buildings
to meet grateful residents in this
so-called impromptu appearance of course
they're in new apartments because the
originals were blown up by the Russians
actually
indicted for overseeing a Mass child
abduction program dismissed by Moscow as
null and void he inspected a new
children's playground
Ukraine dismisses this visit as nothing
more than Putin propaganda it's
certainly not going to make any
difference to the war effort here in
fact it might make people even more
determined to take back muriopol and
make sure Putin can't visit again
much of Mario Paul was destroyed in the
fierce fighting that raised for months
it's from this ruined City that many
children were taken to
russian-controlled territory and across
the border into Russia itself
Olga yarakina is from mariopol driven
from a home by the Russian forces she's
helping to get children returned to
Ukraine and hold Putin personally
responsible Russians came to our land
destroyed my native town for example and
then brought their children under guys
of evacuation rescue and promising a
better future but these children they
had future that had they had their
normal lives in their native town they
had their dreams and the schools and so
on so and so on
Putin is sending a message to the
Russian people that it's business as
usual but it isn't the country's at War
and thousands are dying
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Keith